a short time ago President Trump caused
a commotion with a surprise stroll on
the White House lawn he was swarmed by
reporters after leaving the mansion
president spoke about several issues
including North Korea and a long-awaited
government watchdog report that slams
former FBI director James Comey and
several other agents for their conduct
during the 2016 presidential election we
Jiang is at the White House we he's a
good morning
a good morning earlier this morning the
president tweeted a hint that he might
make an appearance out here on the White
House North Lawn but it was still a
surprise when he did a first first
sitting president and then he talked for
about 30 minutes about everything from
the Russia investigation to Kim
Kardashian to North Korea I think what
he did was a disgrace it was an
extraordinary scene this morning as the
president talked to reporters on the
White House North Lawn he addressed the
OIG report and slammed through FBI
director James Comey they just seem like
very criminal acts to me what he did was
criminal in a rare news conference
yesterday FBI director Christopher ray
acknowledged that mistakes were made
during the 2016 election but noted no
evidence of political bias tainting the
Hillary Clinton investigation nothing in
this report impugns the integrity of our
workforce as a whole but the report does
heavily criticize Comey for not speaking
directly with the Attorney General about
the Clinton email investigation the
report also suggests FBI agent Peter
struck who helped lead both the Clinton
and Russia investigation may have acted
improperly in August 2016 top FBI lawyer
Lisa page texted struck asking Trump's
not ever gonna become president right
right
- which struck replied no no he's not
we'll stop it the president criticized
the FBI for its handling of struck I am
amazed that Peter struck is still at the
FBI and so is everybody else that read
that report the president also defended
his remarks about North Korean leader
kim jong hoon in which he down
Kym's human rights record I don't want
to see a nuclear weapon destroy you and
your family I want to have a good
relationship with North Korea I want to
have a good relationship with many other
countries when the president got back
from his Singapore summit he declared
the nuclear threat from North Korea is
over I pressed him about why he said
that and if he still believes it but the
president would only say he has a great
relationship with Kim Jong hoon and he
does believe North Korea will strike a
deal to give up its nukes we should
thank you the president had a lot to say
this morning